yeah so
um this is oh nathan
hi um
i was having a conversation during the
break about about this topic but it
seems to me that uh
and this i think bridges the gap between
those first those two questions that
professor wolf raise raises there's a
sense in which globalization gives
strong economic value to
interconnectedness and
mr blair you talked about the fact that
people are being forced together by
globalization and there are strong
economic incentives for
interconnectedness and this increased
proximity of people
it seems to me that in a world where
there are these debates between
versions of the good life that religion
creates the fact that globalization
provides a window onto a good life in
which people
take part in shared commerce and shared
ventures um
forces the issue in some sense of
tolerance because it gives strong
incentives for tolerance and in this way
it might be possible that globalization
as much as it's
augmented by faith is actually
augmenting religions in the sense that
it's forcing otherwise
disparate people to come together in
mutual ventures that they wouldn't take
part in otherwise
is this a potential way in which
globalization while it might not contain
values has value
for faiths and religions yeah i agree
that's exactly what i think
so
in fact you can come
yeah i mean the thing is that it
of course
the problem is it does give you a
a window on the world and that can make
you more tolerant but if then there are
people who come in with a
intolerant view then obviously that's
that's when the process can can
can break down but in essence yeah that
i agree that's that's why
there should be a coming together of
those two things and you know just just
to add to this uh when we talk about
influence or globalization on religion
there seems to be very clear impact on
democratization of religion that is
globalization processes seem to have
uh effect of democratizing
religious religious interaction and
undermining top-down authoritarian
structures so you can see a bit of a
correlation between
bottom-up religious movements and
globalization process is progressing
right and that too is a very significant
way in which uh the nature of our
social interaction as defined by
globalization shapes religious landscape